a popular podcast is bringing new
attention to a mysterious disappearance
it's been nearly 25 years since college
freshman kristin smart was last seen
she disappeared after a fraternity party
at california polytechnic
state university where she went to
school for this week's 48 hours jonathan
bigliotti tries to get some answers from
the prime suspect
who's been at the center of the
investigation since day one
podcaster chris lambert grew up near
where kristen disappeared
and remembers passing the billboard with
her face on it
driving past that billboard was a
periodic reminder that oh yeah
they still haven't found that girl more
than two decades later lambert a cbs
news consultant
began investigating what happened to her
the night of may 24
1996. he learned kristin had gone to a
fraternity party
at this house kristen became incredibly
intoxicated
whether she was drugged or whether she
just had a lot to drink in a short
amount of time
she ends up passed out on the lawn next
door
she needed help getting back to campus a
student named paul flores
volunteered to take her back to her dorm
so
if you believe paul's story he goes into
his dorm room
here and he leaves her to walk up this
walkway
her dorm entrance is right over here i
don't think that she went back to her
dorm at all
in fact kristen was never seen again and
flores would become the focus of intense
scrutiny by
law enforcement the smart family and
their lawyer
james murphy every piece of evidence
points directly at paul flores but
flores has
never been charged with anything
kristin's frustrated family blames that
on
numerous missteps by campus police and
the sheriff's office
cal poly's police didn't begin
investigating until kristen had been
gone for four days
and by the time they inspected flores's
dorm room it was empty
and had been thoroughly cleaned there
was a lot of evidence that could have
been gathered
that wasn't why i wish i knew why
from the start kristen's parents have
been relentless in trying to find out
what happened to their daughter
kristen's sister lindsey what toll
over time did this have on your parents
i think they're like carrying boulders
on their back
then in 2011 new sheriff ian parkinson
promised the smarts that solving
kristin's case would be a priority
it has been a slow process but earlier
this year
sheriff's deputies and fbi agents
searched paul flores's home
i thought somebody is taking this
seriously but how much time do you give
them
they've had a suspect since pretty much
day one
good morning i'm jonathan vigliotti with
cbs news were you involved in the
disappearance of kristin smart
wow jonathan vigliotti joins us now so
jonathan what prompted chris lambert to
create this podcast
about kristen smart's disappearance yeah
good morning to you chris lambert grew
up in san luis obispo that's where
kristen smart disappeared back in 1996.
he remembers seeing the news of reading
about it and then of course in the
decades that followed
passing by that billboard with kristen
smart's face on it a few
years ago he decided to do a google
search to see what the latest was
on the case and to his surprise there
wasn't
a lot of information so he did what most
of us would probably not do
he quit his job as an audio engineer and
as a musician so he could
continue this own search in a podcast
that podcast now has
a million listeners and it has really
helped reinvigorate this case we'll take
you step by step
through the latest in the investigation
could there be a break on the way
i'll be looking forward to your
reporting on 48 hours jonathan thank you
very much